The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JAMES SWAN: OK.
Let's go ahead and get started.
We saw a lot of
good conversation
on Piazza this weekend.
So that's good.
Seems like you guys
are making your way
through these two problems
on the latest assignment.
I would try to focus less
on the chemical engineering
science and problems
that involve those.
Usually the topic of interest,
the thing that's useful to you
educationally is going to
be the numerics, right.
So if you get hung
up on the definition
of a particular quantity,
yield was one that came up.
Rather than let that prevent
you from solving the problem,
pick a definition
and see what happens.
You can always ask
yourself if the results
seem physically
reasonable to you
not based on your definition.
And as long as you explain
what you did in your write up,
you're going to get full points.
We want to solve the
problems numerically.
If there's some hang up in
the science, don't sweat it.
Don't let that stop you
from moving ahead with it.
Don't let it make it seem like
the problem can't be solved
or there isn't a
path to a solution.
Pick a definition and go with
it and see what happens, right.
The root of the
second problem is
trying to nest together two
different numerical methods.
One of those is optimization,
and the other one
is solutions of
nonlinear equation,
putting those two
techniques together,
using them in combination.
The engineering science problem
gives us a solvable problem
to work with in that
context, but it's not
the key element of it.
OK, good.
So we're continuing
optimization, right.
Move this just a little bit.
We're continuing
with optimization.
Last time we posed lots
of optimization problems.
We talked about
constrained optimization,
unconstrained optimization.
We heard a little bit
about linear programs.
We started approaching
unconstrained optimization
problems from the perspective
of steepest descent.
OK, so that's where I want
to pick up as we get started.
So you'll recall the idea
behind steepest descent
was all the unconstrained
optimization
problems we're interested
in are based around trying
to find minima, OK.
And so we should think
about these problems
as though we're standing
on top of a mountain.
And we're looking for directions
that allow us to descend.
And as long as we're heading
in descending directions,
right, there's a good
chance we're going to bottom
out someplace and stop.
And when we've
bottomed out, we've
found one of those local minima.
That bottom is going
to be a place where
the gradient of the function
we're trying to find
the minimum of is zero, OK.
And the idea behind
steepest descent
was well, don't just pick any
direction that's down hill.
Pick the steepest
direction, right.
Go in the direction
of the gradient.
That's the steepest
descent idea.
And then we did something a
little sophisticated last time.
We said well OK, I
know the direction.
I'm standing on
top the mountain.
I point myself in the
steepest descent direction.
How big a step do I take?
I can take any size step.
And some steps may be good
and some steps may be bad.
It turns out there are some
good estimates for step size
that we can get by taking
a Taylor expansion.
So we take our
function, right, and we
write it at the next iterate
is a Taylor expansion.
About the current iterate,
that expansion looks like this.
And it will be quadratic with
respect to the step size alpha.
If we want to minimize the
value of the function here,
we want the next
iterate to be a minimum
of this quadratic function.
Then there's an obvious
choice of alpha, right.
We find the vertex of
this quadratic functional.
That gives us the
optimal step size.
It's optimal if our function
actually is quadratic.
It's an approximate, right.
It's an estimation of the
right sort of step size
if it's not quadratic.
And so I showed you here was a
function where the contours are
very closely spaced.
So it's a very steep function.
And the minima is in the middle.
If we try to solve this
with the steepest descent
and we pick different steps
sizes, uniform step sizes,
so we try 0.1 and 1
and 10 step sizes,
we'll never find an
appropriate choice
to converge to the solution, OK.
We're going to have to
pick impossibly small step
sizes, which will require tons
of steps in order to get there.
But with this
quadratic estimate,
you can get a reasonably
smooth convergence to the root.
So that's nice.
And here's a task for you to
test whether you understand
steepest descent or not.
In your notes, I've
drawn some contours.
For function, we'd
like to minimize using
the method of steepest descent.
And I want you to try to draw
steepest descent paths on top
of these contours starting
from initial conditions
where these stars are located.
So if I'm following
steepest descent, the rules
of steepest descent here,
and I start from these stars,
what sort of paths do I follow?
You're going to need
to pick a step size.
I would suggest thinking about
the small step size limit.
What is the steepest descent
path in the small step size
limit?
Can you work that out,
you and your neighbors?
You don't have to do
all of them by yourself.
You can do one, your
neighbor could do another.
And we'll take a look
at them together.
OK, the roar has turned into
a rumble and then a murmur,
so I think you guys are
making some progress.
What do you think?
How about let's do an easy one.
How about this one here.
What sort of path does it take?
Yeah, it sort of curls
right down into the center
here, right.
Remember, steepest descent
paths run perpendicular
to the contours.
So jumps perpendicular to the
contour, almost a straight line
to the center.
How about this one over here?
Same thing, right?
It runs the other way.
It's going downhill 1,
0, minus 1, minus 2.
So it runs downhill and
curls into the center.
What about this one up here?
What's it do?
Yeah, it just runs
to the left, right.
The contour lines
had normals that
just keep it running
all the way to the left.
So this actually doesn't run
into this minimum, right.
It finds a cliff and steps
right off of it, keeps on going.
Steepest descent,
that's what it does.
How about this one here?
Same thing, right,
just to the left.
So these are what
these paths look like.
You can draw them yourself.
If I showed you paths and
asked you what sort of method
made them, you should be able to
identify that actually, right?
You should be able to detect
what sort of methodology
generated those kinds of paths.
We're not always so
fortunate to have
this graphical view
of the landscape
that our method is navigating.
But it's good to have
these 2D depictions.
Because they really
help us understand
when a method doesn't converge
what might be going wrong,
right.
So steepest descent, it
always heads downhill.
But if there is no bottom, it's
just going to keep going down,
right.
It's never going to find it.
Oh, OK.
Here's a-- this is
a story now that you
understand optimization.
So let's see, so
mechanical systems,
conservation of
momentum, that's also,
in a certain sense, an
optimization problem, right.
So conservation of momentum says
that the acceleration on a body
is equal to the sum
of the forces on it.
And some of those
forces are what
we call conservative forces.
They're proportional
to gradients
of some energy landscape.
Some of those forces
are non-conservative,
like this one here.
It's a little damping
force, a little bit
of friction proportional
to the velocity with which
the object moves instead.
And if we start some
system like this,
we give it some initial
inertia and let it go,
right, eventually it's going to
want to come to rest at a place
where the gradient
in the potential is 0
and the velocity is 0 on
the acceleration is 0.
We call that
mechanical equilibrium.
We get to mechanical
equilibrium and we stop, right.
So physical systems many
times are seeking out minimum
of an objective function.
The objective function
is the potential energy.
I saw last year at my house
we had a pipe underground
that leaked in the front yard.
And they needed to
find the pipe, right.
It was like under the asphalt.
So they got to dig up asphalt,
and they need to know
where is the pipe.
They know it's leaking, but
where does the pipe sit?
So the city came out and the
guy from the city brought this.
Do you know what this is?
What is it?
Do you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a dowsing rod.
OK, this kind of crazy
story right, a dowsing rod.
OK, a dowsing rod.
How does it work?
The way it's supposed
to work is I hold it out
and it should turn
and rotate in point
in a direction that's
parallel to the flow
of the water in the pipe.
That's the theory that this
is supposed to work on.
I'm a scientist.
So I expect that
somehow the water
is exerting a force on the
tip of the dowsing rod, OK.
So the dowsing rod
is moving around
as this guy walks around.
And it's going to stop
when it finds a point
of mechanical equilibrium.
So the dowsing
rod is seeking out
a minimum of some potential
energy, let's say.
That's what the physics
says has to be true.
I don't know that flowing
water exerts a force
on the tip of the dowsing rod.
The guy who had this
believed that was true, OK.
It turns out, this is not
such a good idea, though, OK.
Like in terms of a
method for seeking out
the minimum of a potential, it's
not such a great way to do it.
Because he's way up here, and
the water's way underground.
So there's a huge distance
between these things.
It's not exerting
a strong force, OK.
The gradient isn't
very big here.
It's a relatively weak force.
So this instrument is incredibly
sensitive to all sorts
of external fluctuations.
The gradient is small.
The potential energy
landscape is very, very flat.
And we know already
from applying things
like steepest descent
methods or Newton-Raphson
that those circumstances are
disastrous for any method
seeking out minima of
potential energies, right.
Those landscapes are the
hardest ones to detect it in.
Because every point looks like
it's close to being a minima,
right.
It's really difficult to see
the differences between these.
Nonetheless, he figured
out where the pipe was.
I don't think it was
because of this though.
How did he know
where the pipe was?
What's that?
STUDENT: Where the
ground was squishy?
JAMES SWAN: Where the
ground was squishy.
Well yeah, had some
good guesses because it
was leaking up a little bit.
No, I looked
carefully afterwards.
And I think it turned
out the city had come by
and actually painted
some white lines
on either side of the street
to indicate where it was.
But he was out there
with his dowsing rod
making sure the city
had gotten it right.
It turns out, there's something
called the ideomotor effect
where your hand has
very little, you
know, very sensitive
little tremors in it.
And can guide something
like this, a little weight
at the end of a rod to
go wherever you want
it to go when you want it to.
It's like a Ouija board, right.
It works exactly the same way.
Anyway, it's not
a good way to find
the minimum of potential
energy surfaces, OK.
We have the same problem
with numerical methods.
It's really difficult when
these potential energy
landscapes are flat to find
where the minimum is, OK.
So fun and games are over.
Now we got to do some math.
So we talked about
steepest descent.
And steepest descent
is an interesting way
to approach these kinds
of optimization problems.
It turns out, it turns out
that linear equations like Ax
equals b can also be cast as
optimization problems, right.
So the solution to
this equation Ax
equals b is also a minima of
this quadratic function up
here.
How do you know?
You take the gradient
of this function,
which is Ax minus b, and
the gradient to 0 to minima.
So Ax minus b is
0, or Ax equals b.
So we can do optimization
on these sorts
of quadratic functionals, and
we would find the solution
of systems of linear equations.
This is an alternative approach.
Sometimes this is called
the variational approach
to solving these systems
of linear equations.
There are a couple of
things that have to be true.
The linear operator,
right, the matrix here,
it has to be symmetric.
OK, it has to be symmetric,
because it's multiplied
by x from both sides.
It doesn't know that
it's transpose is
different from itself in
the form of this functional.
If A wasn't symmetric,
the functional
would symmetrize it
automatically, OK.
So a functional like
this only corresponds
to this linear equation
when A is symmetric.
And this sort of thing
only has a minimum, right,
when the matrix A is
positive and definite.
It has to have all positive
eigenvalues, right.
The Hessian right,
of this functional,
is just the matrix
A. And we already
said that Hessian needs all
positive eigenvalues to confirm
we have a minima.
OK?
If one of the
eigenvalues is zero,
then the problem
is indeterminate.
The linear problem
And there isn't a single
local minimum, right.
There's going to be a line of
minima or a plane of minima
instead.
OK?
OK, so you can solve
systems of linear equations
as optimization problems.
And people have tried to apply
things like steepest descent
to these problems.
And it turns out
steepest descent is
kind of challenging to apply.
So what winds up
happening is let's
suppose we don't take our
quadratic approximation
for the descent direction first.
Let's just say we take some
fixed step size, right.
When you take that fixed
step size, it'll always be,
let's say good for one
particular direction.
OK, so I'll step in a
It'll be good.
It'll be a nice step
into a local minimum.
But when I try to step in
the next gradient direction,
it may be too big or too small.
And that will depend on
the eigenvalues associated
with the direction that I
am trying to step in, OK.
How steep is this
convex function?
Right?
How strongly curved is
that convex function?
That's what the
eigenvalues are describing.
And so fixed value of
alpha will lead to cases
where we wind up stepping
too far or not far enough.
And there'll be a lot
of oscillating around
on this path that
converges to a solution.
I showed you how to pick
an optimal step size.
It said look in a
particular direction
and treat your function
as though it were
quadratic along that direction.
That's going to be true for
all directions associated
with this functional, right.
It's always quadratic no matter
which direction I point in.
Right?
So I pick a direction
and I step and I'll
be stepping to the minimal
point along that direction.
It'll be exact, OK.
And then I've got
to turn and I've
got to go in another
gradient direction
and take a step there.
And I'll turn and go in
another gradient direction
and take a step there.
And in each direction I go,
I'll be minimizing every time.
Because this step size
is the ideal step size.
But it turns out you can
do even better than that.
So we can step in
some direction, which
is a descent direction,
but not necessarily
the steepest descent.
And it's going to give us
some extra control over how
we're minimizing this function.
I'll explain on
the next slide, OK.
The first thing you
got to do though
is given some descent direction,
what is the optimal step size?
Well, we'll work that
out the same way, right.
We can write f at the
next iterate in terms
of f at the current iterate plus
all the perturbations, right.
So our step method is Xi plus
1 is Xi plus alpha pi, right.
So we do a Taylor
expansion, and we'll
get a quadratic function again.
And we'll minimize this
quadratic function with respect
to alpha i when alpha
takes on this value.
So this is the value of the
vertex of this function.
So we'll minimize this
quadratic function
in one direction,
the direction p.
But is there an optimal
choice of direction?
Is it really best to step
in the descent direction?
Or are there better
directions that I could go in?
We thought going downhill
fastest might be best,
but maybe that's not true.
Because if I point
to a direction
and I apply my
quadratic approximation,
I minimize the function
in this direction.
Now I'm going to
turn, and I'm going
to go in a different direction.
And I'll minimize
it here, but I'll
lose some of the minimization
that I got previously, right?
I minimized in this direction.
Then I turned, I went
some other way, right.
And I minimized
in this direction.
So this will still be a
process that will sort of weave
back and forth potentially.
And so the idea instead is to
try to preserve minimization
along one particular direction.
So how do we choose
an optimal direction?
So f, right, at the
current iterate,
it's already minimized
along p, right.
Moving in p forward
and backwards,
this is going to
make f and e smaller.
That's as small as it can be.
So why not choose p so that
it's normal to the gradient
at the next iterate?
OK, so choose this
direction p so it's
normal to the gradient
at the next iterate.
And then see if that holds for
one iterate more after that.
So I move in a direction.
I step up to a contour.
And I want my p to be
orthogonal to the gradient
at that next contour.
So I've minimized
this way, right.
I've minimized everything
that I could in directions
that aren't in the
gradient direction
associated with
the next iterate.
And then let's see if I can even
do that for the next iteration
too.
So can it make it true that the
gradient at the next iterate
is also orthogonal to p?
By doing this, I get to
preserve all the minimization
from the previous steps.
So I minimize in this direction.
And now I'm going to take a
step in a different direction.
But I'm going to
make sure that as I
take that step in
another direction, right,
I don't have to step
completely in the gradient.
I don't have to go in the
steepest descent direction.
I can project out
everything that I've
stepped in already, right.
I can project out
all the minimization
I've already accomplished
along this p direction.
So it turns out you
can solve, right,
you can calculate
what this gradient is.
The gradient in this
function is Ax minus b.
So you can substitute exactly
what that gradient is.
A, this is Xi plus 2 minus
b dotted with p, right.
This has to be equal to 0.
And you can show that means
that p transpose A times
p has to be equal to 0 as well.
You don't need to be able to
work through these details.
You just need to
know that this gives
a relationship
between the directions
on two consecutive iterates, OK.
So it says if I
picked a direction
p on the previous iteration,
take how it's transposed by A,
and make sure that
my next iteration is
orthogonal to that vector, OK.
Yeah?
STUDENT: So does that
mean that your p's
are all independent
of each other,
or just that adjacent p is?
K, k plus 1 p's are?
JAMES SWAN: This is
a great question.
So the goal with this method,
the ideal way to do this
would be to have these
directions actually
be the directions of
the eigenvectors of A.
And those eigenvectors
for symmetric matrix
are all orthogonal
to each other.
OK?
And so you'll be stepping along
these orthogonal directions.
And they would be all
independent of each other.
OK?
But that's a hard problem,
finding all the eigenvectors
associated with a matrix.
Instead, OK, we pick an
initial direction p to go in.
And then we try to ensure that
all of the other directions
satisfy this conjugacy
condition, right.
That the transformation
of p by A
is orthogonal with the next
direction that I choose.
So they're not
independent of each other.
But they are what we call
conjugate to each other.
It turns out that by doing
this, these sets of directions p
will belong to--
they can be expressed in
terms of many products of A
with the initial direction p.
That'll give you all these
different directions.
It starts to look something
like the power iteration method
for finding the largest
eigenvector of a matrix.
OK?
So you create a
certain set of vectors
that span the entire
subspace of A.
And you step specifically
along those directions.
And that lets you preserve
some of the minimization
as you step each way.
So what's said here is
that the direction p plus 1
is conjugate to the direction p.
And by choosing the
directions in this way,
you're ensuring that p is
orthogonal to the gradient at i
plus 1 and the
gradient i plus 2.
So you're not stepping in the
steepest descent directions
that you'll pick up later
on in the iterative process.
OK?
So when you know which
direction you're stepping in,
then you've got to satisfy
this conjugacy condition.
But actually, this is a
vector in n space, right.
This is also a vector n space.
And we have one equation to
describe all and components.
So it's an
under-determined problem.
So then one has to pick
which particular one
of these conjugate vectors
do I want to step along.
And one particular
choice is this one,
which says, step along the
gradient direction, OK, do
steepest descent,
but project out
the component of the
gradient along pi.
We already minimized along pi.
We don't not have to go in the
pi direction anymore, right.
So do steepest descent, but
remove the pi component.
So here is a quadratic
objective function.
It corresponds to a linear
equation with coefficient
matrix 1 00 10, a diagonal
coefficient matrix.
And b equals 0.
So the solution of the system
of linear equations is 00.
We start with an initial
guess up here, OK.
And we try steepest descent with
some small step size, right.
You'll follow this
blue path here.
And you can see what happened.
That step size was
reasonable as we
moved along the steepest
ascent direction
where the contours were
pretty narrowly spaced.
But as we got down to
the flatter section,
OK, as we got down
to the flatter
section of our
objective function,
those steps are really small.
Right?
We're headed in the
right direction,
we're just taking
very, very small steps.
If you apply this conjugate
gradient methodology, well,
the first step you
take, that's prescribed.
You've got to step
in some direction.
The second step you take
though minimizes completely
along this direction.
So the first step was the
same for both of these.
But the second step was
chosen to minimize completely
along this direction.
So it's totally minimized.
And the third step here
also steps all the way
to the center.
So it shows a conjugate
direction that
stepped from here to there.
And it didn't lose any
of the minimization
in the original direction
that it proceeded along.
So that's conjugate gradient.
It's used to solve linear
equations with order n
iterations, right.
So A has at most n
independent eigenvectors,
independent directions that
I can step along and do
this minimization.
The conjugate gradient method
is doing precisely that.
Doesn't know what the
eigendirections are, but it's
something along these
conjugate directions as a proxy
for the eigendirections.
So it can do minimization
with just n steps for a system
of n equations for n unknowns.
It requires only the
ability to compute
the product of your matrix
A with some vector, right.
All the calculations
there are only
depended on the product
of A with a vector.
So don't have to store A, we
just have to know what A is.
We have some procedure
for generating A.
Maybe A is a linear
operator that comes
from a solution of some
differential equations
instead, right.
And we don't have an
explicit expression for A,
but we have some simulator
that produces, take some data,
and projects A to give
some answer, right.
So we just need this product.
We don't have to
store A exactly.
It's only good for symmetric
positive definite matrices,
right.
This sort of free energy
functional that we wrote
or objective function
we wrote only
admits symmetric matrices
which are positive definite.
That's the only way it
will have a minimum.
And so the only way a steepest
descent or descent type
procedure is going to
get to the optimum.
But there are more
sophisticated methods that
exist for arbitrary matrices.
So if we don't want symmetry
or we don't care about
whether it's positive
definite, there
are equivalent sorts of
methods that are based
around the same principle.
And it turns out, this is
really the state of the art.
So if you want to solve
complicated large systems
of equations, you know
Gaussian elimination, that
will get you an exact solution.
But that's often infeasible
for the sorts of problems
that we're really interested in.
So instead, you use these
sorts of iterative methods.
Things like Jacobi
and Gauss-Seidel,
they're sort of the
classics in the field.
And they work, and you can
show that they converge on
are lots of circumstances.
But these sorts of
iterative methods,
like conjugate gradient and its
brethren other Krylov subspace
methods they're
called, are really
the state of the art, and
the ones that you reach to.
You already did conjugate
gradients in one homework,
right.
You used this PCG
iterative method in Matlab
to solve a system
of linear equations.
It was doing this, right.
This is how it works.
OK?
OK.
OK, so that's
country ingredients.
You could apply it also to
objective functions that
aren't quadratic in nature.
And the formulation
changes a little bit.
Everywhere where the
matrix A appeared
there needs to be
replaced with the Hessian
at a certain iterate.
But the same idea persists.
It says well, we think
in our best approximation
for the function that
we've minimized as much
as we can in one direction.
So let's choose a conjugate
direction to go in,
and try not to ruin
the minimizations we
did in the direction
we were headed before.
Of course, these are all
linearly convergent sorts
of methods.
And we know that
there are better ways
to find roots of non-linear
equations like this one,
grad f equals zero, namely
the Newton-Raphson method,
which is quadratically
convergent.
So if we're really close
to a critical point,
and hopefully that critical
point is a minima in f,
right, then we should
rapidly converge
to the solution of this
system of nonlinear equations
just by applying the
Newton-Raphson method.
It's locally convergent, right.
So we're going to get close.
And we get quadratic
improvement.
What is the Newton-Raphson
iteration, though?
Can you write that down?
What is the
Newton-Raphson iteration
that's the iterative
math for this system
of non-linear equations,
grad f equals 0?
Can you work that out?
What's that look like?
Have we got this?
What's the Newton-Raphson
iterative map
look like for this system
of non-linear equations?
Want to volunteer an answer?
Nobody knows or
nobody is sharing.
OK, that's fine.
Right, so we're trying to solve
an equation g of x equals 0.
So the iterative map is Xi
plus 1 is Xi minus Jacobi
inverse times g.
And what's the Jacobian of g?
What's the Jacobian of g?
The Hessian, right.
So the Jacobian of
g is the gradient
of g, which is two
gradients of f, which is
the definition of the Hessian.
So really, the
Newton-Raphson iteration
is Xi plus 1 is Xi minus
Hessian inverse times g.
So the Hessian plays the
role of the Jacobian,
the sort of solution procedure.
And so everything you
know about Newton-Raphson
is going to apply here.
Everything you know about
quasi-Newton-Raphson methods
is going to apply here.
You're going to substitute
for your nonlinear.
The nonlinear function
you're finding the root for,
you're going to
substitute the gradient.
And for the Jacobian,
you're going
to substitute the Hessian.
Places where the Hessian is, the
determent of the Hessian is 0,
right it's going
to be a problem.
Places where the
Hessian is singular
is going to be a problem.
Same as with the Jacobian.
But Newton-Raphson
has the great property
that if our function is
quadratic, like this one is,
it will converge in
exactly one step.
So here's steepest
descent with a fixed
value of alpha,
Newton-Raphson, one step
for a quadratic function.
And why is it one step?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES SWAN: Good.
So when we take a Taylor
expansion of our f,
in order to derive the
Newton-Raphson step,
we're expanding it out
to quadratic order,
its function is quadratic.
The Taylor expansion is exact.
And the solution of
that equation, right,
gradient f equals
0 or g equals 0,
that's the solution of a
linear equation, right.
So it gives exactly the
right step size here
to move from an initial
guess to the exact solution
or the minima of this equation.
So for quadratic equations,
Newton-Raphson is exact.
It doesn't go in the steepest
ascent direction, right.
It goes in a
different direction.
It would like to go in the
steepest descent direction
if the Jacobian were identity.
But the Jacobian is a
measure of how curved f is.
The Hessian, let's say, is a
Right?
And so there's a
projection of the gradient
through the Hessian that
changes the direction we go in.
That change in
direction is meant
to find the minimum of the
quadratic function that we
approximate at this point.
So as long as we have a good
quadratic approximation,
Newton-Raphson is going to give
us good convergence to a minima
or whatever nearby
critical point there is.
If we have a bad
approximation for a quadratic,
then it's going to
be so good, right.
So here's this very
steep function.
Log of f is quadratic, but
f is exponential in x here.
So you got all these tightly
spaced contours converging
towards a minima at 00.
And here I've got to use
the steepest descent step
size, the optimal steepest
descent step size, which
is a quadratic approximation
for the function,
but in the steepest
descent direction only.
And here's the path
that it follows.
And if I applied Newton-Raphson
to this function,
here is the path that
it follows instead.
The function isn't quadratic.
So these quadratic
approximations aren't--
they're not great, right.
But the function
is convex, right.
So Newton-Raphson is
going to proceed downhill
until it converges towards
a solution anyways.
Because the Hessian has positive
eigenvalues all the time.
Questions about this?
Make sense?
OK?
So you get two different
types of methods
that you can play with.
One of which, right, is always
going to direct you down hill.
Steepest descent will always
carry you downhill, right,
towards a minima.
And the other one,
Newton-Raphson,
converges very quickly when
it's close to the root.
OK, so they each have a virtue.
And they're different.
They're fundamentally
different, right.
They take steps in completely
different directions.
When is Newton-Raphson not
going to step down hill?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
What's that?
JAMES SWAN: OK,
that's more generic
an answer than I'm looking for.
So there may be circumstances
where I have two local minima.
That means there must be
maybe a saddle point that
sits between them.
Newton-Raphson doesn't
care which critical point
it's going after.
So it may try to approach
the saddle point instead.
That's true.
Yeah?
STUDENT: When
Hessian [INAUDIBLE]..
JAMES SWAN: Good, yeah.
With the Hessian doesn't have
all positive eigenvalues,
right.
So if all the eigenvalues
of the Hessian are positive,
then the transformation h
times g or h inverse times g,
it'll never switch the
direction I'm going.
I'll always be headed
in a downhill direction.
Right?
In a direction that's
anti-parallel to the gradient.
OK?
But if the eigenvalues
of the Hessian
are negative, if some
of them are negative
and the gradient has
me pointing along
that eigenvector in
a significant amount,
then this product
will switch me around
and will have me
go uphill instead.
It'll have me chasing down
a maxima or a saddle point
instead.
That's what the
quadratic approximation
of our objective
function will look like.
It looks like there's a
maximum or a saddle instead.
And the function
will run uphill.
OK?
So there lots of strengths
to Newton-Raphson.
Convergence is one
of them, right.
The rate of convergence is good.
It's a locally
convergent, that's good.
It's got lots of
weaknesses, though.
Right?
It's going to be a pain
when the Hessian is
singular at various places.
You've got to solve
systems of linear equations
to figure out what
these steps are.
That's expensive
computationally.
It's not designed
to seek out minima,
but to seek out critical points
of our objective function.
Steepest descent has
lots of strengths, right.
Always heads
downhill, that's good.
If we put a little quadratic
approximation on it,
we can even stabilize it and get
good control over the descent.
Its weaknesses are
it's got the property
that it's linearly convergent
instead of quadratically
convergent when it converges.
So it's slower, right.
It might be harder
to find a minima.
You've seen several examples
where the path sort of peters
out with lots of little
iterations, tiny steps
towards the solution.
That's a weakness
of steepest descent.
We know that if we
go over the edge
of a cliff on our
potential energy landscape,
steepest descent it just
going to run away, right.
As long as there's
one of these edges,
it'll just keep running downhill
for as long as they can.
So what's done is to try
to combine these methods.
Why choose one, right?
We're trying to step our
way towards a solution.
What if we could
craft a heuristic
procedure that mixed these two?
And when steepest descent
would be best, use that.
When Newton-Raphson
Yes?
STUDENT: Just a quick
question on Newton-Raphson.
JAMES SWAN: Yes?
STUDENT: Would it
run downhill also
if you started it over there?
Or since it seeks
critical points,
could you go back up
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
JAMES SWAN: That's
a good question.
So if there's an
asymptote in f, it
will perceive the asymptote as
a critical point and chase it.
OK?
And so if there's an
asymptote in f, if can
perceive that and chase it.
It can also run away as
it gets very far away.
This is true.
OK?
The contour example that I
gave you at the start of class
had sort of bowl shape
functions superimposed
with a linear function, sort
of planar function instead.
For that one, right, the
Hessian is ill-defined, right.
There is no curvature
to the function.
But you can imagine adding
a small bit of curvature
to that, right.
And depending on the
direction of the curvature,
Newton-Raphson may run downhill
or it may run back up hill,
right?
We can't guarantee which
direction it's going to go.
Depends on the details
of the function.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah?
Good.
STUDENT: Sir, can you just
go back to that one slide?
JAMES SWAN: Yeah.
I'm just pointing out,
if the eigenvalues of h
is further negative, then
the formula there for alpha
could have trouble too.
JAMES SWAN: That's true.
STUDENT: Similar to how the
Newton-Raphson had trouble.
JAMES SWAN: This is true.
This is true, yeah.
So we chose a quadratic
approximation here, right,
for our function.
We sought a critical point of
this quadratic approximation.
We didn't mandate that
it had to be a minima.
So that's absolutely right.
So if h has negative eigenvalues
and the gradient points
enough in the direction
of the eigenvectors
associated with those
negative eigenvalues,
then we may have a case
where alpha isn't positive.
We required early on
that alpha should be
positive for steepest descent.
So we can't have a case
where alpha is not positive.
That's true.
OK.
So they're both
interesting methods,
and they can be mixed together.
And the way you mix
those is with what's
called trust-region ideas, OK.
Because it could be that
we've had an iteration
Xi and we do a
quadratic approximation
to our functional, which
is this blue curve.
Our quadratic approximation
is this red one.
And we find the minima
of this red curve
and use that as our next
best guess for the solution
to the problem.
And this seems to be
working us closer and closer
towards the actual
minimum in the function.
So since quadratic
approximation seems good,
if the quadratic
approximation is good,
which method should we choose?
STUDENT: Newton-Raphson.
JAMES SWAN:
Newton-Raphson, right.
Could also be the
case though that we
make this quadratic
approximation
from our current
iteration, and we
find a minimum that somehow
oversteps the minimum here.
In fact, if we look at the
value of our objective function
at this next step, it's
higher than the value
of the objective function
where we started.
So it seems like a quadratic
approximation is not so good,
right.
That's a clear indication that
this quadratic approximation
isn't right.
Because it suggested that we
should have had an minima here,
right.
But our function
got bigger instead.
And so in this case,
it doesn't seem
like you'd want to
choose Newton-Raphson
to take your steps.
The quadratic approximation
is not so good.
Maybe just simple steepest
descent is a better choice.
OK, so it's done.
So if you're at a point,
you might draw a circle
around that point with
some prescribed radius.
Call that Ri.
This is our iterate Xi.
This is our
trust-region radius Ri.
And we might ask, where does
our Newton-Raphson step go?
And where does our steepest
descent step take us?
And then based on whether
these steps carry us
outside of our trust-region,
we might decide
to take one or the other.
So if I set a
particular size Ri,
particular trust-region size
Ri and the Newton-Raphson step
goes outside of that,
we might say well,
I don't actually trust my
quadratic approximation
this far away from
the starred point.
So let's not take a
step in that direction.
Instead, let's move in a
steepest descent direction.
If my Newton-Raphson step
is inside the trust-region,
maybe I'll choose
to take it, right.
I trust the quadratic
approximation
within a distance Ri of
my current iteration.
Does that strategy makes sense?
So we're trying to pick
between two different methods
in order to give us more
reliable convergence
to a local minima.
So here's our
Newton-Raphson step.
It's minus the Hessian
inverse times the gradient.
Here's our steepest
descent step.
It's minus alpha
times the gradient.
And if the
Newton-Raphson step is
smaller than the
trust-region radius,
and the value of the
objective function at Xi,
plus the Newton-Raphson
step is smaller
than the current
objective function,
it seems like the
quadratic approximation
is a good one, right.
I'm within the region in which
I trust this approximation,
and I've reduced the
value of the function.
So why not go that way, right?
So take the Newton-Raphson step.
Else, let's try taking a step in
the steepest direction instead.
So again, if the steepest
ascent direction is smaller
than Ri and the
value of the function
in the steepest
descent direction,
the optimal steepest descent
direction or the optimal step
in the steepest ascent
direction is smaller
than the value of the
function at the current point,
seems like we should
take that step.
Right?
The Newton-Raphson
step was no good.
We've already discarded it.
But our optimized
steepest descent step
seems like an OK one.
It reduces the value
of the function.
And its within the
trust-region where
we think quadratic
approximations are valid.
If that's not true, if the
steepest descent step takes us
outside of our
trust-region or we
don't reduce the
value of the function
when we take that step,
then the next best strategy
is to just take
a steepest ascent
step to the edge of the
trust-region boundary.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Is there a reason
here that Newton-Raphson
is the default?
JAMES SWAN: Oh, good question.
So eventually we're going to get
close enough to the solution,
all right, that all these
steps are going to live
inside the trust-region ring.
Its going to require
very small steps
to converge to the solution.
And which of these two methods
is going to converge faster?
STUDENT: Newton-Raphson.
JAMES SWAN: Newton-Raphson.
So we prioritize Newton-Raphson
over steepest descent.
That's a great question.
Its the faster
converging one, but
its a little unwieldy, right.
So let's take it
when it seems valid.
But when it requires
steps that are too big
or steps that don't minimize f,
let's take some different steps
instead.
Lets use steepest
descent as the strategy.
So this is heuristic.
So you got to have some rules to
go with this heuristic, right.
We have a set of conditions
under which we're going
to choose different steps.
We've got to set this
trust-region size.
This Ri has to be set.
How big is it going to be?
I don't know.
You don't know, right, from
the start you can't guess
how big Ri is going to be.
So you got to pick
some initial guess.
And then we've got to modify
the size of the trust-region
too, right.
The size of the trust-region
is not going to be appropriate.
One fixed size is not going to
be appropriate all the time.
Instead, we want a strategy
for changing its size.
So it should grow or shrink
depending on which steps we
choose, right.
Like if we take the
Newton-Raphson step
and we find that our
quadratic approximation is
a little bit bigger than
the actual function value
that we predicted, we might
want to grow the trust-region.
We might be more
likely to believe
that these Newton-Raphson
steps are getting us
to smaller and smaller
function values, right.
The step was even better
than we expected it to be.
Here's the quadratic
approximation
in the Newton-Raphson direction.
And it was actually bigger
than the actual value
of the function.
So we got more, you know, we
got more than we expected out
of a step in that direction.
So why not loosen up, accept
more Newton-Raphson steps?
OK, that's a
strategy we can take.
Otherwise, we might think
about shrinking instead, right.
So there could be
the circumstance
where our quadratic
approximation predicted
a smaller value for the
function than we actually found.
It's not quite as reliable
for getting us to the minimum.
These two circumstances
are actually these.
So this one, the
quadratic approximation
predicted a slightly
bigger value than we found.
Say grow the
trust-region, right.
Try some more
Newton-Raphson steps.
Seems like the Newton-Raphson
steps are pretty reliable here.
Here the value of the function
in the quadratic approximation
is smaller than the
value of the function
after we took the step.
Seems like our trust-region
is probably too big
if we have a
circumstance like that.
Should shrink it a
little bit, right?
We took the Newton-Raphson
step, but it actually
did worse than we
expected it to do
with the quadratic
approximation.
So maybe we ought to shrink the
trust-regional a little bit.
And you need a
good initial value
for the trust-region radius.
What does Matlab use?
It uses 1.
OK.
It doesn't know.
It has no clue.
It's just a heuristic.
It starts with 1 and it
changes it as need be.
So this is how fsolve solves
systems of nonlinear equations.
This is how all of the
minimizers in Matlab, this
is the strategy they use
to try to find minima.
They use these sorts of
trust-region methods.
It uses a slight improvement,
which is also heuristic,
called a dogleg
trust-region method.
So you can take a
Newton-Raphson step
or you can take a
steepest descent step.
And if you found the steepest
descent step didn't quite
get you to the boundary
of your trust-region,
you could then step in the
Newton-Raphson direction.
Why do you do that?
I don't know, people have
found that it's useful, right.
There's actually no
good reason to take
these sorts of dogleg steps.
People found that for general,
right, general objective
functions that you might
want to find minima of,
this is a reliable
strategy for getting there.
There's no guarantee that
this is the best strategy.
These are general
non-convex functions.
These are just hard problems
that one encounters.
So when you make a software
package like Matlab,
this is what you do.
You come up with heuristics
that work most of the time.
I'll just provide you
with an example here, OK.
So you've seen this
function now several times.
Let's see, so in red
covered up back here
is the Newton-Raphson path.
In blue is the optimal
steepest descent path.
And in purple is the
trust-region method
that Matlab uses
to find the minima.
They all start from
the same place.
And you can see the
purple path is a little
different from these two.
If I zoom in right up
here, what you'll see
is initially Matlab chose to
follow the steepest descent
path.
And then at a certain point it
decided, because of the value
of the trust-region that
Newton-Raphson steps were
to be preferred.
And so it changed
direction and it
started stepping along the
Newton-Raphson direction
instead.
It has some built in
logic that tells it
when to make that
choice for switching
based on the size
of the trust-region.
And the idea is just to
choose the best sorts of steps
possible.
Your best guess at what
the right steps are.
And this is all based
around how trustworthy we
think this quadratic
approximation
for objective function is.
Yeah, Dan?
STUDENT: So for the trust-region
on the graph what Matlab
is doing is at
each R trust-region
length it's reevaluating
which way it should go?
JAMES SWAN: Yes.
Yes.
It's computing
both sets of steps,
and it's deciding which
one it should take, right.
It doesn't know.
It's trying to
choose between them.
STUDENT: Why don't you do
the Newton-Raphson step
through the [? negative R? ?]
JAMES SWAN: You can do that
as well, actually, right.
But if you're
doing that, now you
have to choose
between that strategy
and taking a steepest descent
step up to R as well, right.
And I think one has to decide
which would you prefer.
It's possible the Newton-Raphson
step also doesn't actually
reduce f.
In which case, you should
discard it entirely, right.
But you could craft a strategy
that does that, right.
It's still going to
converge, likely.
OK?
OK.
I've going to let
you guys go, there's
another class coming in.
Thanks.